no se logra solucionar el fenómeno de
las quemas ilegales sabemos de ellas
pero no se ve una política fuerte para
erradicarlas
muchas gracias un gusto sí bueno estamos
viendo un aumento exponencial de
incendios en principio porque estamos
atravesando una crisis climática cuyas
consecuencias se ven materializadas
incendios olas de calor etcétera no
concretamente en brasil por lo que
mencionabas que es una época de quemas
en áreas y fueron taladas ya sea de
forma legal o ilegal y teniendo en
cuenta que esta malla estos incendios
fueron provocados
ahora esto responde a su vez y
fundamentalmente a una voluntad política
enfocada a fomentar la deforestación la
minería y la agricultura ganadería en
zonas de la amazonía e incluso en zonas
de alta sensibilidad ecológica asimismo
responde a una debilidad institucional
que no permite un control efectivo
de la gestión ambiental
como se ve afectada fernando la
población local y cuáles son los efectos
medioambientales
bueno fundamentalmente está la pérdida
de biodiversidad no hay aquí cabe
recalcar que la amazonía comprende
muchos ecosistemas frágiles esenciales
para la vida humana estamos hablando del
mayor pulmón vegetal del mundo
asimismo de manera directa la salud
humana se ve afectada mediante el humo
la ceniza y la calidad del aire no
también es importante comprender que los
incendios forestales y el cambio
climático se exacerban mutuamente
por un lado las altas temperaturas y el
aumento de la sequía que genera el
cambio climático hace que los incendios
tengan una temporada más prolongada y
por otro lado los incendios se
intensifican con el cambio climático al
devastar ecosistemas sensibles y ricos
en carbono como las selvas tropicales
que complejiza el control del aumento de
la temperatura
bueno y las cifras oficiales muestran
que desde que ya ir bolsonaro asumió el
cargo en enero de 2019 la deforestación
media anual en la amazonía ha aumentado
un 75% en comparación con la década
anterior estas son cifras que se vienen
manejando desde hace tiempo ya aquí la
pregunta si hay un cambio de mando
podría ser distinto el panorama ustedes
qué opinan
sin duda evidentemente hay ciertas
dinámicas ambientales que ya responden a
cuestiones geopolíticas pero con una
voluntad política y diferente que haga
que la política pública sea guiada por
la bioética que genere mecanismos de
control incluso con fiscalización y
participación ciudadana sin duda se
puede generar una regeneración ambiental
importante y construir mecanismos y
permanentes acciones masivas y
multidimensionales para la prevención y
control efectivo de los incendios así
como para la regeneración ambiental y
con voluntad política la gestión
ambiental puede ser mucho más efectiva y
esto es fundamental cuando el cambio
climático nos sitúa en un momento
histórico sin presidentes pues